they saturated his body with gasoline
under chained em to the top of the
schoolhouse they didn't set fire to the
base don't even stay alive above the
crackling of the funnies you can hear
this young man screaming I didn't do it
I'm Tennyson
[Music]
many people know about the terror of
lynchings but one of the reasons why
blacks were lynched was to suppress the
black vote which is still happening
today
I'm black I'm from the south and so this
means a lot to me because my answers
just relaxed my research examines the
extent to which historical lynchings or
correlated with voter registration rates
of blacks today and what I find is that
blacks who currently reside in counties
that were exposed to a higher number of
lynchings are less likely to register to
vote and they are less likely to
indicate that they voted in a recent
election compared to their white
counterparts
voting is a social norm why are you
voting because the people around you are
voting but what happens if their parents
didn't vote and their parents didn't
vote in their parents and vote all of
this is rooted in historical racial
animus what happens if you can walk
outside and see a body hanging from a
tree
[Music]
image Hills lynching is very iconic in
American history he was a
fourteen-year-old boy from Chicago who
supposedly whistled at a white woman and
was kidnapped tortured beaten killed and
body was dumped in a river when one of
his killers was interviewed the first
reason he gave for killing Emmett Till
was voting that as long as he lived and
as long as he could do anything about it
[__] weren't gonna vote in his area
because if they did they control the
government
lynching since the signal you vote you
die you have no protection you have no
rights we will kill you that's the power
of lynching
[Music]
the rise of lynching was after slavery
now african-americans were no longer
property and now they had to be put back
in their subjugated place all the
southern problem born three hundred
years ago with the introduction of
slavery is that of the Negro today in
Dixie there are almost nine million
colors like we actually seen as a
political threat in a lot of southern
counties blacks were the majority and so
when black men were given the right to
vote if they voted a certain way they
could actually change the political
structure of the south this outraged
many white Southerners in particular the
KKK and waited to responded to this was
with lynchings from 1890 to 1920
we had a lynching on average one every
other day
[Music]
legends were a show they were a public
spectacle
you have this festival of violence
you've got community involvement you've
got the person being tortured before the
crowd and dismembered they even sold
people's body parts as souvenirs for
individuals to purchase and they would
bring their children to these lynchings
you had judges police officers
politicians sometimes standing by or
even participating by the evening quite
a group of people had gathered at the
jail the sheriff went down and had a toy
to dammam after brutalizing him they
chained him to a back of a car and then
dragged him through the black community
the impact of lynching in black
communities was profound you really do
not trust local officials because in
fact they were engaged in the domestic
terrorism rained down on your community
this mistrust of local officials has
been passed down culturally among blacks
lynching was a method for voter
suppression although we don't have the
bodies hanging in the trees the past is
never in the past
[Music]
I believe that empowering black people
to vote is actually a way of saying that
their ancestors died for a reason so
that we could have the right to vote and
we are actually holding today
you